George Soros and his son Alex Soros
who's taking over the George Soros
leftwing financing
Empire they have just maxed out
donations to Joe Biden's 2024
reelect now maxing out donations is a
little bit misleading here because we
have all these weird campaign Finance
rules maxing out donations means they
each gave
$6,600 which is nothing that's the
amount of money they make every time
they blink okay $6,600 is not going to
matter at all to the campaigns now they'
also given qued million to the Biden
Victory fund which is much less
regulated than the actual candidate
Campaign Committee but the reason that
they're doing this is not about the six
grand or whatever 12 13 Grand and it's
not about even the quar million dollars
it's about signaling to the rest of the
left that the big dog funders are still
with Biden the hardest hit person here
is Gavin Nome